shark tank is the most popular business
venture capital show it in the world I
mean what's more motivating than
watching aspiring entrepreneurs try to
pitch their ideas and take their
companies to the next level but while
shark tank is no doubt entertaining it
that's all it should be used for
entertainment do you think like uh you
can get me 1.3 million for educating
these Bobo's up here for the last five
years shark tank is a terrible
representation when it comes to what
goes down in a real VC pitch so much of
what we see here is completely staged
and just for the camera not to mention
it the producers like to warp what
really happens to make it more
entertaining for us viewers for example
an entrepreneur may only stumble once in
an hour-long pitch but given that these
pitches are condensed into just 10 to 15
minutes it seems like their entire pitch
was a train wreck not to mention it the
business advice that the sharks give it
is often Hit or Miss now don't get me
wrong here shark tank is a phenomenal
show and I've been a fan for several
years but we need to be able to separate
between entertainment and real
entrepreneurship because shark tank is
not that great when it comes to the
latter
starting off with the biggest issue no
one on Shark Tank is actually there to
make a deal you see it with the real VCS
the only reason anyone is there is to
make a deal investors want to invest
their money to make returns while
entrepreneurs need an investment to grow
their business but on Shark Tank the
only reason anyone is there is for
publicity if an entrepreneur is there
only to make a deal then they're just
naive most of them know that the second
that their episode airs their business
is gonna blow up this is one of the
reasons that Shark Tank businesses have
such a high success rate in fact only
six percent of Shark Tank businesses
have gone out of business once they get
to momentum from Shark Tank they're able
to achieve the economies of scale that
they need to turn their startup into a
legitimate company but what this also
means is that getting an investment from
the Sharks themselves is not the main
reason that they're there the real
benefit of pitching on the tank is not
convincing the Sharks but convincing you
the viewer so really it's just one big
infomercial meanwhile from the shark's
perspective they have no monetary reason
to make deals either the primary reason
the sharks are there is to promote their
own personal brand image I mean just
think about this how much money could
the Sharks even make from these deals in
the first place take Mark Cuban for
example his median investment size is
125 000 and this median stake is 20
virtually none of the deals that he
makes have any chance of reaching the
billion dollar Mark more times than not
these are small Niche businesses that
would be lucky to reach the 10 million
dollar Mark maybe the strongest out of
them could reach 100 million from the
entrepreneur's perspective this is
awesome if you own a hundred million
dollar business or even a 10 million
dollar business you're probably set for
life but how much does this matter for
Mark a 20 stake in a 10 million dollar
business is only 2 million dollars with
a net worth of 5.83 billion dollars this
increases his net worth by a whopping Z
0.03 percent even if we're talking about
a hundred million dollar cash out that's
only 20 million for Mark or a 0.3
increase in net worth and that sophistic
doesn't get watered down by new
investors now of course the other sharks
aren't desperate to Mark Cuban but even
for them they'd be lucky to grow their
net worth by 10 through all the
Investments they ever make on Shark Tank
the same however cannot be said about
the publicity they receive how many more
people will recognize the Mavericks
because they see Mark Cuban on TV every
week how many more people will watch QVC
because these are Lorry on Shark Tank
and how many people didn't even know
about FUBU until they saw diamond on
Shark Tank this is where the real money
is for the Sharks take the Mavericks for
example onto a shark tank started
gaining traction and they were worth
about 400 million dollars but over the
last 10 years they've grown all the way
to 2.7 billion dollars which is a 2.3
billion dollar profit for Cuban now you
could argue that this gain evaluation is
due to the team itself becoming better
but to that I would argue that the main
reason the team became better was
because of all the publicity Mark got
the team as the Mavericks became more
recognizable they became a more
desirable team to play for which of
course attracts better Talent this same
argument could be made for the brand
values of FUBU and the Herjavec group as
well clearly for both the Sharks and the
entrepreneurs the money is not in the
deal it's in the publicity so how could
such a show possibly set realistic
expectations regarding venture capital
for aspiring entrepreneurs
foreign
that much of the show is just one big
publicity stunt I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that a significant
portion of the deals that are made on
air never make it to the other side in
fact with most sharks the odds of a deal
actually being completed are basically
just a coin flip the only shark that has
a high completion rate is Mark who comes
in at 87.5 percent and honestly this is
likely a strategic play by Mark as well
the Investments that he makes are not
consequential to his wealth so being a
man of his word is more important than
potentially making a bad investment the
average viewer will likely never see
these stats but I'm sure the people who
actually make pitches are well aware of
them when they see that Mark has a far
higher closing rate than the other
sharks they'll likely be motivated to
get a deal with a mark on TV this will
come off as entrepreneurs consistently
choosing Mark over everyone else which
is again a great first brand image now
choosing to not complete a deal because
the fundamentals of a startup don't
match up is completely find it and
perfectly understandable the problem
however is that the downsides of
business are rarely shown on the show
The overwhelming majority of the show
has to do with showing off this
idealistic vision of success we see
sharks shaking hands in these big
corporate rooms in front of these giant
mansions but this is not what happens in
real life even for Rich business people
like the Sharks most of these guys are
actually pretty low-key and live pretty
modest lives but this doesn't align with
the producer's vision so they just make
stuff up a perfect example of this is
with Chris Saka Chris is literally what
the show is supposed to be about Venture
capitalists and startups that make it
big Chris was an early investor in Uber
and this made him a billionaire so you
would think that he fits this mold
perfectly but his real life wasn't
nearly exciting enough for the show
first The Producers asked to film at his
house but when they realized he lived in
a three-bedroom house in Truckee
California they were quick to back out
next they asked a film in front of his
private jet but Chris doesn't actually
own a private jet Waki does fly private
he finds that it's far more economical
to Simply rent a Jet when he needs one
hearing this they wanted to shoot in
front of his supercars and boats but the
most expensive car that Chris owns is a
Tesla and he doesn't own a boat running
out of options it has to film at his HQ
but his VC format doesn't have a fancy
HQ either in fact he does most of his
deals from his home to spend more time
with his family according to Chris The
Producers quote didn't know how to make
me look rich to America and they told
him that he has to overcompensate for a
shirt and eventually they decided to
just pick the look they filmed in a
random conference room of one of the
companies that Chris owns and they
staged some sort of billionaire wine
celebration in someone's patio when
you're struggling to portray a real VC
billionaire to the public there's no
question that there's something wrong
with how you're trying to portray them
instead of giving us a real look into
the lives of the Sharks and
entrepreneurs more times than not were
just shown success porn
aside from ulterior motives and the
misleading visions of success what goes
on in the tank is also not something to
learn from first of all the vast
majority of businesses that come onto
Shark Tank are product oriented
businesses this isn't a buy random
Chance The Producers specifically choose
products that viewers can relate to also
the businesses that generally want to be
on Shark Tank are companies that can
benefit from public exposure if your
business provides back-end support for
Walmart this wouldn't be all that fun
for viewers to watch the problem however
is that most successful startups are
exactly this when was the last time you
heard about a clothing or food startup
that makes it to a billion dollars
almost all unicorns have to do with
attack yet we rarely see this on the
show if you're a real entrepreneur you
would have a much better shot at making
it if you try to fulfill some Niche role
in Tech then try to start any of the
businesses on the show also if you do
start a business and are trying to raise
money you shouldn't take inspiration
from Shark Tank's evaluations because
more times than not there rip-offs I'm
sure we're all familiar with those
entrepreneurs that offer like five
percent of their company for half a
million dollars this is a terrible idea
in the tank because the sharks are gonna
rip you apart but in the real VC world
this is extremely common most of the
businesses that we see on Shark Tank are
in what you would call series a funding
series a is usually the first time
entrepreneurs ask VCS to invest until
this point the startup is usually funded
by the entrepreneurs and their friends
and family and the average valuation of
series a funding isn't half a million or
1 million like we see on Shark Tank the
average evaluation in it is 22 million
dollars and the average raised is 13
million dollars even city funding rounds
which comes before series a have higher
valuations than what we see on Shark
Tank the average seed valuation at as of
2018 was nearly 6 million dollars and
these businesses generally have zero
Revenue so to see businesses with six
figures if not seven figures in sales
get lower valuations on Shark Tank is
quite comical the only reason that
sharks are able to demand such high
valuations is because they're
essentially celebrity endorsers if
you're simply looking for money you'll
be able to find a far more reasonable
valuations amongst real VC firms not to
mention it you almost certainly won't be
ridiculed VC investors aren't going to
tell you that you're dead to them if you
come back to them in a later round of
funding with more results they may very
well invest because all they care about
is returns they don't care about
upholding some sort of TV Persona
something else to note is that you won't
have 10 seconds to accept the deal
either honestly this is pretty
ridiculous selling a portion of your
company especially at a lower evaluation
than you asked for it is a pretty big
decision but the Sharks really give you
time to think or talk about it so if
you're truly looking to raise money
don't take any inspiration from a shark
tank because you're just asking it to be
ripped off
foreign
I know this video has been quite
critical about Shark Tank but it's not
all bad for many shark tank may be what
motivates them to take their first step
into entrepreneurship and Shark Tank
does teach people about the basic traits
that investors look for and how to raise
money but Shark Tank shouldn't be taken
any more seriously than this most of the
entrepreneurs and sharks are there for
publicity not to make deals similarly
much of their show is built upon this
fake vision of success instead of the
real grinder behind businesses and most
importantly in terms of actually raising
money shark tank isn't all that great
now of course there are some exceptions
if you're a product oriented business
want publicity and would like a
celebrity business person on your side
then Shark Tank could be an option for
you but for most entrepreneurs Tech and
traditional BC firms are likely Your
Best Bets and you shouldn't take shark
tank as anything more than just
entertainment but that's just what I
think do you think shark tank should
offer a more realistic view into VC
funding comment that down below also
drop a like if you're a fan of shark
tank for entertainment and of course
consider joining our Discord Community
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one